Speaker 1: Let's go next to Barry
from Milwaukee. Barry, welcome.
Speaker 2: Hi, David, can you hear me?
Speaker 1: Yes, I can.
Speaker 2: Yeah, I had a question if you were,
you know, canvasing in Milwaukee,
Wisconsin, one of these swing states,
and you were talking to a voter and you were
saying this is the biggest accomplishment of
the Biden administration, what would you bring up?
Speaker 1: I mean, so here's the thing about it.
I think right now there is a few of what I would
consider the major Biden accomplishments, and it
would depend on who I'm talking to. So I would
need to know more about what a Wisconsin voter
is likely to care about. But I would say that
the infrastructure package, the vaccine rollout,
COVID stimulus and getting out of Afghanistan
would be the four big accomplishments. One. Judge
Jackson is confirmed to the court, and I believe
she will be. I would also add that to the list
as the five big Biden accomplishments so far. But
which one I would list depends on who I'm talking
to and what I believe they care about. Right.
Speaker 2: Yeah, I mean, that makes sense. I just
what I wanted to put on your radar because, you
know, I've been doing voter outreach in the state
for a few years now is just like knocking doors
right now and phone calls are very hard. People
are plugged out are very negative. And so I'm I'm
worried about the possible wins we could have in
the future for the next couple of years.
Speaker 1: Right. Well, listen,
I mean, a one at this point, seeing the
three Supreme Court justices that Trump got
and now that Joe Biden is getting
one, I can't imagine any only the most
kind of depraved bury your head in the sand.
Democrats at this point would fail to see.
Imagine if Hillary had gotten those three Supreme
Court picks. OK. And think about Roe v. Wade
might go away. Look at what's happening with all
of these different issues that now are going to
the Supreme Court, and we have one of the most
right wing courts we've had in a really long time.
Just think back how this would have been different
if Hillary had won. And that should really remind
us of when Joe Biden now gets one pick. The
people who wrote off the Supreme Court is
an irrelevant issue. Wow, wow. I hope that
they feel ashamed, ashamed of themselves.
Speaker 2: You know, David, that that's
that's actually was really helpful in
motivating me to, you know, keep at it. Thank you.
Speaker 1: Thank you. All right. Very good. Keep.
Yes, absolutely. Keep at it. Let's take a quick
break. We're going to keep taking calls. So don't
hang up if you're holding. We're just taking a
very quick break and then we'll be right back